cela va être compliqué découvrir les
évacuations de migrants errent le
conseil d'état a validé l'éloignement
des gens la liste si nécessaire lors de
ces opérations
le juge des référés a débouté deux
journalistes qui n'avaient pas pu
pénétrer dans les périmètres de sécurité
instauré leur d'évacuation de migrants à
calais près de dunkerque
les 29 et 30 décembre dernier par le
conseil d'état cette mise à l'écart ne
porte pas atteinte à la liberté de la
presse la protection de l'ordre public
qui prime selon l'institution
on va en parler tout de suite avec
dominique pradalié secrétaire générale
du syndicat national des journalistes
bonjour à vous dominique pradalié merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
d'abord selon concède et à la liberté de
la presse n'est pas en remise en cause
que répondez vous c'est stupéfiant de
voir que les deux juridictions
administratives ont repris les arguments
du ministère de l'intérieur en faisant
complètement fi de la liberté de la
presse
la première décision à lille assurait
qu'il n'y avait pas matière à s'émouvoir
car les évacués sans décès c'est ce qui
est un gros mensonge et le conseil
d'état a rappelé que la liberté de la
presse est une très bonne chose mais a
déclaré que les mesures prises ne serait
pas attaqué donc nous sommes stupéfaits
et ainsi mécontents car s'asseoir comme
ça sur la liberté de la presse est
dramatique en france on a vu lors de
l'expulsion de la république où il n'y
avait pas de périmètre les méthodes
brutales et est sans appel des forces de
police contre les réfugiés
là on ne pourrait plus constaté les facs
que des tentes sont déchirés les objets
volés les pièces d'identité perdu égaré
ou même voler le journaliste ne pourrait
même pas vérifier ces informations
qu'elles soient donnés par les migrants
ou qu'elles soient donnés par la police
et c'est pour ça que nous avons décidé
je pense que nous allons aller juste
au fond le conseil d'état nous dit
quelque chose de stupéfiant il nous dit
il nous écrit dans sa décision d'hier
dans son ordonnance d'hier s'il n'est
pas sérieusement je le cite
s'il n'est pas sérieusement contesté
qu'elle soit rendue nécessaire pour des
motifs de sécurité
il est en revanche soutenu que les
distances imposées les contrôles
d'identité qui les accompagnent font
obstacle à l'exercice effectif du métier
de journaliste en ce qu'elles ne sont ni
adaptée ni proportionnée et nonobstant
cette phrase il déclare irrecevable
notre recours donc comprenne qui pourra
et dans cette décision on voit aussi
cette incongruité assez choquant de
constater que ce serait pour préserver
la vie privée des réfugiés quand on
écartera les journalistes voyez où en
sont tombés
certaines décisions des juridictions
administratives
alors vous dites que vous n'allez pas en
rester là y at il des recours possibles
pour faire valoir justement le droit des
journalistes d'être présent lors
d'opération d'évacuation alors là il y
avait c'était un recours en référé donc
nous pouvons aller en recours au fonds
pour que le conseil d'état se positionne
complètement clairement et puis s'ils ne
nous donnent pas satisfaction nous irons
jusqu'à strasbourg bien évidemment
devant la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme mais c'est quand même lamentable
de constater que les autorités sont en
toute illégalité et que les journalistes
et paul ne pourrait pas tout à l'heure
vous parler des conséquences justement
de cette décision du conseil d'état à ce
qu'il faut craindre des dérapages parce
que c'est vrai on
on l'a vu que parfois leur d'opération
d'évacuation c'était la place de la
république notamment à paris parfois ses
muscles
je ne sais pas si le veau musclé est
approprié ce qui est certain c'est que
le droit des réfugiés n'est pas
respectée que les journalistes qui
peuvent le constater et le dire sont de
moins en moins nombreux et de plus en
plus écartée des lieux où les événements
se poursuivre
c'est très choquant parce que ça ça à
toutes les les ça ouvre toutes les
possibilités de maltraitance et
d'habilité alors juste un dernier point
rapidement lapin selon le conseil d'état
la protection de l'ordre public
l'emportent sur la liberté d'informer
comment vous recevez vous cet argument
pour terminer c'est un argument repris
directement du de la plaidoirie du
ministère de l'intérieur et nous avons
demandé sans obtenir aucune réponse
qu'on nous cite un seul cas un seul cas
où les journalistes
orange est née une action policière ou
de gendarmerie quelle qu'elle soit nous
le demandons toujours et nous n'avons
jamais de réponse donc c'est un faux
argument
merci beaucoup à vous dominique pradalié
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat national
des journalistes